كان عام 2022 هو عام السفر الانتقامي
محليًا ويبدو أن عام 2023
سيكون عام السفر الانتقامي
دوليًا مع إزالة جميع القيود المرغوبة.
للزيادة هذا العام حيث يقوم
الجميع برحلات الأحلام هذه حول
العالم وأين توجد أفضل الصفقات التي يمكن
العثور عليها الآن ،
لذلك من المثير للاهتمام أننا بدأنا في
رؤية بعض الصفقات محليًا حتى الأماكن
التي كانت ساخنة حقًا أثناء الوباء
مثل وايومنغ مونتانا ألاسكا  أماكن بها
حدائق وطنية بدأنا نشعر
برؤية بعض الصفقات هناك وأيضًا أماكن
مثل هاواي ، لذا كانت هاواي
باهظة الثمن بالنسبة لمعظم عام 2022 ، لكننا
بدأنا نرى بعض صفقات رحلات الطيران بعض
عروض الفنادق ، لذا تحقق بعناية من حجز
الرحلات الدولية الآن لأننا
بدأنا نشهد ارتفاع الأسعار على
المستوى الدولي ولكن هذا هو المكان
الذي ما زلنا نجد فيه أفضل الصفقات ، هناك
شركات طيران جديدة منخفضة التكلفة مثل Nor  في حد ذاتها ،
تنخفض الأسعار إلى أماكن مثل أوسلو ،
نشهد الكثير من الصفقات إلى لشبونة إلى
البرتغال ، لذا اشترك في مواقع
مثل Points Guy اشترك في رسالتنا
الإخبارية ونرسل
التجار كل يوم تقريبًا ونرى
تنبيهات الصفقات المنتظمة  لذلك ، في حين أن الأسعار أعلى
بشكل عام ، لا يزال هناك الكثير من الصفقات التي لا يزال
يتعين إجراؤها ، إلا أن اليوم الأول من
العام الجديد هو الوقت المناسب لشراء رحلة ،
أعتقد أن الطلب سيكون
مرتفعًا حقًا ، حيث يرغب الأشخاص في إبداء
الإعجاب بك.  إجازة ،
وبالتالي قد تكون الأسعار أعلى في يوم
مثل اليوم من يوم الثلاثاء الذي لا أعرفه بشكل عشوائي في
الصباح الباكر أو
شيئًا ما ستفاجأ به حقًا
لأننا انتهينا للتو من
موسم العطلات المزدحم حقًا والمكلف حقًا.
لا تهدأ المسافرين من رجال الأعمال أو عدد قليل جدًا من
مسافري الترفيه ، لذا
تنخفض الأسعار فعليًا في العام الجديد ، لذا إذا
كنت على استعداد للذهاب في فصل الشتاء ،
فهناك الكثير من الصفقات الموجودة هناك حتى في
أوروبا تذكر أن الدولار الأمريكي لا يزال
قوي إلى حد ما بحيث يساعدك في بعض
الصفقات ولكن هناك الكثير من الصفقات إذا كنت على
استعداد للخروج من الموسم أو
موسم الكتف نسميها أه عندما لا تكون الحشود موجودة